so we have the function f of X is equal
to X to the sixth minus 3x to the fifth
and we want to know over what intervals
is f decreasing and we're going to do it
without even having to graph y equals f
of X and the way we do that is we look
at the derivative of F with respect to X
and think about well when is that less
than zero if that if the rate of change
of F with respect to X is less than zero
well over those intervals it will be
decreasing so let's first take the
derivative so f prime of X is going to
be equal to just use the power rule here
it's going to be 6x to the fifth power
minus 5 times 3 is 15 X to the let's
decrease that exponent by 1 X to the
fourth power and so let's think about
when this is going to be less than zero
over what intervals is 6 x to the fifth
minus 15 X to the fourth less than less
than zero so let's see we could factor
out a 3x to the fourth so 3x to the
fourth times if we factor out a 3x to
the fourth here we'll just be left with
the 2x minus 5 is less than zero did I
do that right let's see if I were to
distribute it three times two is six
X to the fourth times X is X to the
fifth 3 times 5 is 15 and x to the
fourth yep that's right so if I'm doing
the product of two things and I want it
to be less than a zero well there's only
one way for that to happen is that one
or X you say there's two ways for that
to happen either the first thing is
positive and the second is negative or
the first is negative and the second is
positive and so let's do that so either
either 3x to the fourth is negative and
and 2x minus five is positive or let me
just put the or in a separate color here
or 3x to the fourth is positive and
two X minus five is negative so let's
see this is X to the fourth three X to
the fourth being less than zero well if
we divide both sides by three this is
just going to be X to the fourth needs
to be less than zero and is there any
way for something to be to the fourth to
the fourth power to be less than zero
well we're assuming we're dealing with
real numbers here and any real number to
the fourth power is going to be greater
than or equal to zero so it's actually
impossible for something to the fourth
power to be less than zero this thing is
never this thing is never going to be
less than zero
so we can actually rule out this first
case so we can rule out that first case
right over there and so we're only going
to worry about this case so 3x to the
fourth being greater than zero well
that's going to happen as long as X is
not equal to zero so this is because for
any other X this is going to be true X
could be negative you take it to the
fourth power multiply it by three it's
going to be greater than zero so this is
really just the condition that X cannot
be equal to zero
and let's see the second one 2x minus
five less than zero that means two X is
going to be less than five and then X is
less than five halves so as long as X is
less than five halves and X is not equal
to zero this thing will be decreasing so
if we wanted to write it in terms of if
we wanted to write it in terms of
intervals we could say X is let me do
this in a new color just to ease the
monotony so we could say that I'm in
trouble picking color so we could say
that X is less than zero or zero is less
than X is less than five halves so X is
less than zero this is all the negative
values and then we're essentially just
excluding zero and then going all the
way to all the way to five halves and
remember I just all I did is this in the
world what is our first derivative
negative because if the first derivative
is negative then the rate of change of F
with respect to X
is negative or F is decreasing as X is
increasing